let's discuss the reality of the double
standard in america the idea that some
people if they're the right people get
special treatment
while others suffer politically driven
attacks at the hands of media
and law enforcement this week the
department of justice turned its
rating of rudy giuliani's new york
apartment into a full-blown production
providing new content for the liberal
media to drool over
meanwhile the doj has been keeping the
hunter biden investigation awfully quiet
doesn't seem like we'll be seeing any
big raids involving him certainly in the
coming months
he is a democrat president's son after
all joining me now with reaction is
arkansas senator tom cotton
he is of course a member of the
judiciary committee senate committee
senator welcome aboard thanks for
joining me
tammy thanks for having me on appreciate
it so so you know what's fascinating
here and as the american people see it
is that we see certain aggressive
actions regarding some people but not
others i would say that's one reason why
president trump was elected
in the first place in 2016 was this
seemingly sense of an
imbalance between with law and order and
the rule of law and who it was applied
to
what do you make of uh the timing of uh
this uh
raid on the mayor uh and uh happening on
the night of the uh state of the union
effectively
and of course hunter biden who is
actually under investigation which a lot
of people might not know
he's going to be teaching a course at
tulane university
while he's under investigation what do
you make of all of this
well tammy there is a deep double
standard that pervades the left in
america it's not just in our government
uh but as you point out there was a
sensational raid
of mayor giuliani's apartment i don't
know the grounds for that i don't know
where the status of the investigation is
so i can't comment on it
but hunter biden is under investigation
and that investigation should be pretty
sprawling whether it's lying to the
bureau of
alcohol tobacco and firearms on gun
applications
or potentially working with foreign
agents in ukraine and china
and other countries as well but you're
right we haven't seen any high
uh profile raids of hunter biden's homes
or offices or anything else
but again this double standard pervades
the left i mean just look at amazon
i sent a letter today to jeff bezos
asking why they pulled
a highly acclaimed documentary of
clarence thomas during black history
month from their streaming service
yet they were still offering for free
documentaries about left-wing terrorists
like the weather underground
or just consider what happened today to
tim scott i mean social media companies
today
allowed the left to smear tim scott
after his outstanding speech last night
as an uncle tim attacking him for the
color of his skin that went on for hours
today
how long do you think it would have
taken twitter to pull down those posts
if it was about say kamala harris or
barack obama
you this is what concerns us of course
because you've got big tech
controlling the conversation in the
country making decisions
that are racist right this is this is a
a curated decision when it came to
allowing that to run
about uh senator scott for 11 hours that
this is
part of the democrat playbook it's it's
hand in hand when it comes to smearing
especially minorities who don't conform
but really anyone josh hawley gets
cancelled his book from simon schuster
it tells the american people that you
will be punished
but we are seeing of course i think we
have a good history as the american
people to not put up with this
uh how do you see congress do they have
a role
we know there's always meetings what can
we do to push
further on this when it comes to either
legislation or more pressure from the
government for them to stop it
well tammy when it comes to congress's
role over the executive branch we have
to conduct oversight if you recall from
the obama era it was in part congress's
efforts
that exposed the fact that the obama irs
is targeting
any group with the name tea party in its
name for additional
auditing and harassment when it comes to
some of these
woke corporate ceos like the ceos of
delta or coca-cola anytime they start
parroting left-wing lies like they did
about georgia's entirely sensible
election law
we need to speak out we can't roll over
uh and we have to defend
common-sense principles against these
left-wing mobs whether they originate on
social media or in the corporate
boardroom
you see and i think this is key because
people are looking
to to know what the rhetoric can be that
they're not alone in thinking that this
is awful because that's the other
message when they hear you sir
when they hear other of their favorite
people pushing back
that it's that they're not alone that
there is a way to say no to this
that we can prevail as long as we don't
surrender
to their effort to silence us and you're
leading that and i appreciate that
senator thanks for joining me today
all right thank you my